[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
pour cette soirée exceptionnelle de
débat sur france 3 des débats consacrés
aux élections municipales dont le
premier tour se déroulera je vous le
rappelle le 15 mars des échanges des
controverses des critiques les
programmes d idc sur france 3 en
première partie de soirée on en est très
fière et après chalon cap sur nevers
nevers 33 mille habitants il y en a eu
45 milles à l'extrémité ouest de la
bourgogne franche comté nevers qui
regarde autant vers la région centre que
vers la bourgogne nevers étape
touristique pour tous les amoureux du
val de loire mais nos verres ville qui
perd aussi des habitants et qui subit
les difficultés classiques des villes
moyennes attractivité économique
enclavement perte des services publics
départ de la jeunesse entretient parfois
compliqué de son patrimoine
nevers longtemps fief socialiste tombé
il ya six ans sous les coups d'une
alliance menée par denis thuriau et pour
en débattre six invités sur notre
plateau bonjour denis curio bonjour vous
êtes le maire sortant depuis 2014
investi pour ce scrutin de 2020 par la
république en marche vous ne cachez pas
votre soutien au président emmanuel
macron nathalie charvy bonjour vous
mener une liste europe écologie pcf en
binôme avec le communiste françois diot
et des socialistes sur votre liste vos
mobiles lte moyens et des citoyens
damian beaudry bonjour vous êtes la tête
de liste du rassemblement national pour
ces élections municipales bonjour
philippe morel d'un jeu on vous a connu
candidat de droite à la mairie en 2001
conseiller régional udf et vous êtes
cette fois soutenu par entre autres la
section locale du parti socialiste
section qui n'a pas suivi les choix du
ps national karine roy daguin bonjour
gino sans étiquette politique vous mener
une liste de rassemblement citoyen et
emilie chamoux bonjour vous êtes membre
de la france a soumis ce vous mener
cette liste avec d'autres partis de
gauche dont le soutien du parti
socialiste national
pour revenir à ce qu'on disait
précédemment rajoutons que dominique
dupuis mène une liste pour lutte
ouvrière nous lui donnerons la parole
dans le courant de cette émission
au menu trois thèmes pour vos échanges
et une conclusion d'une minute pour tout
le monde
conclusion tirée au sort avant le début
de cette émission on commence tout de
suite par une thématique qu'on retrouve
dans la plupart des villes moyennes
l'attractivité c'était votre cheval de
bataille de nicolas hulot il ya six ans
on s'en souvient
au bout d'un mandat pour utiliser une
expression à la mode nevers est elle
sortie de la diagonale du vide
on va le demandez à vos opposants
d'abord nathalie charvet oui une vert
souffre comme beaucoup de villes milian
bien entendu on se rend dans les
quartiers en ce moment et on voit
combien les noeuds vers soi peuvent
souffrir pour autant pour il est clair
que pour nous le rebond économique ne
viendra pas de las vegas je crois que
plutôt que de rêver de faire comme dans
comme les métropoles 1 et je pense en
particulier à ce que j'ai entendu en
conseil d'agglo à savoir qu'on allait
faire de nevers une nouvelle silicon
valley il faut s'appuyer sur nos atouts
le sens de l'histoire c'est des villes
écologiques c'est des villes humaines au
cadre de vie préservé
c'était une ville industrielle je vais y
venir juste après donc nous pensons
qu'il faut d'abord engager une
mobilisation générale pour la défense
des services publics et la défense de ce
qui existe des industries on a perdu 260
emplois avec aïssa d'industrie philippe
classe ennemis etc
dans le même temps malheureusement la
cub on n'affiche que trente emplois on a
toutes les missions on va avancer sur
cette idée de notre activité de la villa
mais déjà vous partager ce point de vue
tout à fait je rejoins complètement le
point de vue de nathalie servi dans le
sens où à mon avis le premier mauvais
choix c'est de choisir de se rallier à
la république en marche qui ne leur est
pas du tout dans le sens de l'intérêt
général pour la défense des services
publics dont les villes moyennes comme
la nôtre on entend le besoin pour
renforcer le soutien dont ont besoin les
écoles la santé et tous les ai tous les
services dont les citoyens ont besoin
dans ce rapport de proximité et la plus
ça va plus nous nous éloignons de nos
services publics qui sont notre bien
commun la réplique en marche ça vous
écarte de de tout le mouvement de verre
avenir il existait en 2013 2014
c'est lui qui a remporté l'élection
c'est lui qui se représente au suffrage
j'en suis l'un des porte paroles mais je
suis surtout une équipe
moi je suis investi la république en
marche la plupart de mes colistiers ne
le sont pas voilà alors cette
intelligence de différentes sont dans
cette attractivité
et qui en 2014 était sur la table de ce
débat qu'on avait faits divers vous
savez quand on a un premier mandat c'est
mon cas j'en sors je restais un amateur
de la politique je le revendique
on sème des graines il égrène elles
finissent par pousser ce qui est en
train de se faire maintenant fou du
temps c'est beaucoup vous avez rappelé
comment la ville a chuté je pense qu'il
faut être modeste où les élus sur le
développement de l'industrie
je voudrais pas rappeler mais notamment
est la liste écologique et solidaire et
communistes également que pendant qu'ils
étaient au pouvoir
juste avant nous il ya eu des chutes il
y a eu
vous n'êtes falcom ni les élus ni zim il
ya rue rotos des centaines d'emplois
parce que pourquoi parce que sont pas
les élus plus où les industries sont pas
les élus qui font les choix stratégiques
et si aujourd'hui à quelques entreprises
qui malheureusement sont en difficulté
comme dans toutes les villes médiane
c'est parce que notamment dans
l'automobile thermique
on sait que ce n'est plus l'avenir et
qu'elles n'ont pas forcément fait les
bons choix maintenant j'ai fait le choix
de l'innovation
mais l'innovation intelligentes quand
nathalie charvy matadi vous dites que la
cub ses trente emplois il faudra réviser
vos comptes
aujourd'hui on est à 124 emplois
précisément je signe de beaux la semaine
prochaine l'entreprise québécoise qui
s'installe à des verts qui vont créer de
l'emploi avec le technicentre
aujourd'hui on a presque 200 à la loire
et le village balcère c'est pas tout
seul et aujourd'hui la nouvelle économie
la nouvelle économie il faut pas
l'éloigner du reste personne ne sait pas
que la nouvelle expo mais la réponse en
tout cas quand je vois le développement
de nos parcs d'activités économiques
aujourd'hui je vends des terrains pour
pas le combat national on va continuer à
l'être les industries les en soit je
vous laisse pas partir trop loin et
donne la parole aux autres licences dont
il est question ne sont que des emplois
délocalisés ses trente emplois fictifs
en plus avec lui non plus à négliger
est ce que vous connaissez pas d'accord
avec des termes dont on va le voir
malheureuse c'est dommage de réduire
l'emploi malgré sa déclaration sur le
naturisme
le maire sortant de la république en
marge fait preuve d'un singulier
professionnalisme
alors bien sûr diagonale du vide et
spirale du déclin en l'état actuel
puisque on a une perte drastique des
habitants 2500 habitants de 2012 à 2017
un taux de pauvreté qui est actuellement
sur le verre sont les dernières
statistiques avoisine les 22 %
alors que sur l'ensemble de la nièvre il
est de 15 et des poussières pour alors
vous feriez quoi ah qu'est-ce que je
fais bien la preuve ils recommencent pas
fait je veux dire la première chose que
je fais au lendemain de notre élection
c'est de convoquer de réunir une
conférence de l'ensemble des entreprises
ne vernois 9 et reçoivent parce que je
suis persuadé que c'est au sein de notre
territoire que nous trouverons sans
doute des solutions à l'emploi et puis
aussi un simple aux yeux des
associations qui ont été maltraités
pendant ces six dernières années et qui
touche à l'humain de façon à ce que nous
puissions avoir le pouls de la
population
on avance dans cet échange
carry-le-rouet dagg sur sur ce sujet-là
sur l'attractivité de la ville est ce qu
on dit souvent que ma mère était une
ville moins en moins attractive en tout
cas ce qu'à ce mandat donc oui les
usines ont fermé les magasins aussi et
pourtant dès 2017 les marcheurs ont
décidé d'en faire leur laboratoire
une smart city alors perfusé perfusé
subventions égayé de visites
ministérielles
les nouvelles technologies ne
nourrissent pas le neuf et reçoit pas
c'est clair
monsieur le maire se prévaut de
plusieurs dizaines d'emplois créés dans
l'incubateur à start up il se félicite
d'un coup ça 3-0 nommé victor à
destination des ehpad new pouvoir
ingénieurs du cru parade sous literie
ou le passage piéton de lagnieu cavret
vouvoie dont les blouses blanches salut
des on a posé un orteil
ce sont dix sept mille euros ou sur le
pot en est de 56 projecteurs à 200000
euros
je ne pense pas que ça crée vraiment une
attractivité
après activités au diané donnell du vide
ouais je dirais ni l'une ni l'autre
parce que on que tout le monde connaît
le bilan de nos verres et c'est vraiment
un message d'espoir et d'espérance que
je vais envoyer au nova reçoit ce soir
est de dire que nevers c'est une
capitale rural qui doit jouer de ce qui
doit jouer avec ses voisins avec les
ruraux avec eux le pôle de performance
qu'on à magny cours
on a plein de richesses sur nevers et
sur son agglomération qui peuvent faire
de nevers une belle et grande ville mais
à quoi il faut mettre en place les
choses pour que nos verts soit vraiment
la locomotive de cette agglomération et
de ce département
sans forcément rentrer dans ce système
des métropoles qui dévitalise les
communes françaises mais bien d'avoir un
fort soutien de la ville et bien sûr
être cette locomotive qui soutient les
services publics qui met en place les
entreprises et qui soutient cadre de vie
exigeante
un petit mot avant de refermer ce
chapitre sur la partie centre ville
on se souvient que c'était aussi un des
grands sujets il ya six ans lors des
élections par des élections municipales
vous allez nous dire parce que on a eu
pas mal de médiatisation sur des choses
qui ont été faites à nevers je pense à
la gratuité du stationnement je pensais
des mesures fiscales sur les loyers les
locaux inoccupés
est ce que ça vous semble être une bonne
solution pour faire vivre revitaliser
centre-ville de nos verts dont on sait
qu'ils avaient un des records de
vacances commercial c'est-à-dire de
boutiques fermées alors il se trouve que
ça n'a pas changé il suffit de voir la
rue du commerce ou la rue saint martin
la vacance commercial est toujours la
même et en cela du nid curieux n'a pas
réussi à infléchir à infléchir le
phénomène alors pour nous le
centre-ville c'est le lieu du commerce
mais c'est aussi le lieu de l'échangé de
la convivialité et de la culture dans
notre programme ya un certain nombre de
projets on veut préempter les cellules
commerciales de façon à les réhabiliter
allait proposer
selon des loyers modérés on veut aussi
par exemple qu'il y ait hausse au sein
du centre ville des lieux qui soit par
exemple destinés à l'enseignement
supérieur par exemple l'ex banque de
france ça pourrait être un lieu où on
pourrait mettre 200 à 300 étudiants
c'est une façon aussi de revitaliser le
centre ville
et puis il ya une mesure qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur pour protéger
le commerce de proximité
c'est le moratoire contre l'extension
des zones commerciales périphériques de
retour pour nous c'est comme ça qu'on
peut protéger le commerce a mené chameau
le les mesures qui ont été prises pour
le centre-ville elle vous semble
intéressante précisant pas efficace non
pour nous c'est inefficace on le fait il
faut absolument faire revenir les
habitants au centre ville pour que les
commerces ils revivent et notamment des
commerces de proximité
puisqu'on voit que actuellement les
personnes qui vivent en périphérie bout
dans les quartiers périphériques du
centre ville n'ont pas les moyens de
déplacement par exemple le réseau de bus
n'est pas suffisamment couvrant pour que
des personnes âgées par exemple puissent
se déplacer sur les zones commerciales
qui actuellement existent et les
nouvelles soient ont envie de pouvoir
revenir en centre ville de manière plus
simple est de se rendre en centre ville
s'était pas de mesure alors la gratuité
du stationnement ne résout pas du tout
où les problèmes puisque l'on voit que
beaucoup se plaignent notamment de
devoir revenir toutes les deux heures
changer leurs disques donc ça ne résout
pas le souci ce qu'il faut mettre en
place c'est une concertation avec les
noeuds vers soi afin qu'ils puissent
donner leur avis sur la manière dont ça
fonctionne peut-être avec un système de
pastilles pour les résidents du centre
ville et surtout nous ce que nous
souhaitons développer c'est un système
de transport urbain gratuit en tendant
vers la gratuité dans un premier temps
pour les jeunes mais qui petit à petit
ce sera gratuit pour tous avec des
parkings dans les zones extérieures
ce qui permettra
ou non vers soi de se rendre plus
simplement centre ville tout en
respectant l'environnement
l'unrwa à gaza vous semble être un sujet
important centre ville oui il faut
revitaliser le centre ancien on peut
mettre en place une pépinière des arts
et de l'artisanat en centre ville ce
serait déjà une bonne idée
installée depuis 8 rue urbain pour
pour les commerçants également renforcer
le dialogue avec les propriétaires de
commerces faire débat mauvaise idée bail
dérogatoire soutenir la démarche de
collaboration de commerçants qui se
partagent un bail construire sur
internet les amener aussi internet une
brute une place commerçante qui regroupe
cinq dix commerçants par exemple des
commerces de bouche constituer une
livraison urbaine innovante et
éco-responsable on peut la faire en vélo
pour répondre à l'évolution des modes de
travail créé des communes des
communautés des changes participatif des
espaces de qu encourager la création
d'une monnaie locale
c'est quelque chose aussi qui pourrait
faire quelque chose et puis proposer des
animations commerciales originales aux
commerçants ce qui veut dire parce que
on peut comprendre en creux dans la
liste de vos propositions que ça ça
n'existe pas original non
ce ne sont pas des jeux ne sont pas des
animations qui sont originales c'est
vrai qu'en période d'élection au futur
you a vraiment mis le paquet on a un
petit train qui circule depuis le mois
de décembre et qui veut circuler jusqu
en avril les transports je pense que si
on va y venir de façon spécifique sur
les transports denys thuriau c'était un
des thèmes avant soyez courageux et
portés important on vous a vu dans les
médias là dessus les médias nationaux
sur particulier des locaux commerciaux
vides
ça a pas l'air d'être évident pour je me
posais pas tant de soutien d'ailleurs
mais ça m'étonne pas ça je crois pour
être mère faut bien connaître sa ville
et puis les yaka fokon sa marque pour
personne donc je voulais simplement
rappelé que vous arrêtez de tout
caricaturer ça ne fonctionne pas nos
verts est loin d'être dans la diagonale
du vide on est au centre de la france
vous évoquiez le centre loire
effectivement vers lequel nous tourner
aurait régulièrement mais moi je me
tourne surtout à présent paris et
l'économie je vais la chercher là bas
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui notre chance
c'est justement d'être à moins de deux
heures de paris avec des transports qui
vont s'améliorer
je vois quelqu'un la vie dans son
programme c'est trop tard c'est déjà
fait on va passer avec des nouveautés en
moins de deux heures des deux heures
pour aller à dijon 2h07 je les ai obtenu
auprès de la préfète de région ça
de ma part donc on améliore les choses
après le catastrophisme
arrêtons 6,9 pour cent de chômage à 9 r
c'est encore de trop mais c'est bien
plus bas qu'on l'était avant 2014 voilà
on a atteint parfois jusqu'à neuf
courses minimes et 22 6% sous les
blessés vers les gens
j'ai eu la courtoisie de pas vous couper
il ya quelqu'un qui a dit avant moi je
vous demande de vous arrêter
moi je vous demande de vous arrêter pour
que puisse continuer et donc je n'avais
rien les 13 millions 8,2 subventions que
je vais chercher haut niveau de l'état
on me le reproche mais c'est d'autant
moins que les 2 versions dépenser on dit
que le taux de vacance commercial n'a
pas évolué c'est faux il est passé à 18
% et 1 24 % il ya six ans on me dit même
la rue saint martin n'a pas évolué et
plus rien aujourd'hui il ya quatre
commerces nouveau il y en a deux qui
atteint donc arrêtons de caricatures
négative et sinon je pense pas que c'est
intéressant d'être meilleur quand on
voit pas les choses objectivement alors
moi je vais vraiment les pastilles c'est
interdit je le dis à madame chamoux
pouvait pas partir dans le stationnement
est gratuit 650000 euros par an je
laisse aux gens pouvait pas attribuer du
domaine public par des pastilles c'est
la loi qui l'interdît donc ce n'est pas
possible
vous portez vous sur la gratuité du bus
moi je veux bien qu'on en parle
et si je suis réélu près en
agglomération s'est adjugé je mettrai
sur la table parce qu'on commande a
réfléchi à longeau n'allons pas nous y
allons c'est parce que ça nous ouvre un
peu sur le test suivant qui était gardé
les jeunes on est à gauche ça coûte 2
millions de de plus aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire que vous allez
augmenter les impôts donc dit claude à
versoix si vous les transports gratuits
il ya la gratuité n'existe pas il
toujours un payeur donc si c'est pas
l'usagé c'est le contribuable donc faut
dire une averse voies qui vont payer au
moins deux millions de plus de
perception de la tva par l'agglomération
si c'est gratuit alors je vous pose d'un
couple parce qu'il ya des gens qui
attendent patiemment et qui ne sont pas
transparents créatures certain nombre de
millions programmés ou simplement sur ce
qui a été dit alors tout n'est pas
mauvais dans le programme du du maire
sortant c'est évident moi ce que je lui
reproche c'est un manque de concertation
évident les populations n'ont pas été
concertés sur nos noms mais vos amis
mais pas les autres
à noter sur ces aménagements le plan de
circulation demande
incontestablement à être revu et puis il
faut être imaginatif fois je pense par
exemple à nos amis suédois ou hollandais
qui ont des centres des grandes surfaces
autour des centres villes et qui impose
pratiquement à chaque grande surface
d'avoir un magasin en centre ville
d'abord ça peut être un hymne magasin ou
un magasin à magasins de proximité et
les personnes âgées en particulier
peuvent y aller plus facilement
et puis confort gratter un mot quand
même parce que ça traverse un peu zappé
vous allez bientôt écouter non mais je
vous aurais je suis assez d'accord non
pas sur les transports gratuits tu vois
que il faut toujours faire payer quelque
chose
donc moi c'est ses partisans d'un
transport à 1 euro que pourront utiliser
les gens en fonction de leurs
déplacements
mais certains cas une amélioration à
faire à ce niveau là via d'autres
transports qui existent comme la
coccinelle et cetera dont ceux d'un pur
coccinelle continue à cortina luis et sa
cour mais je commence je le comprend
aisément dernier voudrait on enchaîne
pour que oui que les blancs secs et vous
attendez pas se mêler à redire sur
plusieurs choses donc monsieur thuriau
vous parliez que les neuf et reçoit ont
fait le choix en 2014 de suivre votre
ligne politique mais je peux rappeler
que la démocratie n'est pas forcément
une fois tous les six ans que des
référendum peuvent être mis en place de
réelles référendum pas des consultations
une fois que les travaux sont terminés
ou les gens n'ont finalement plus de mot
à dire ensuite je voulais rebondir ou
tout à l'heure vous parliez de de
graines à germer la rue du 14 juillet
vous l'avez fait en début de mandat la
graine elles germent à quel moment des
restaurants qui se porte bien
qui fonctionne très bien oui des
restaurants qui existait déjà avant où
sont les nouveaux habitants qu'ils
devaient qui devait arriver où sont les
nouveaux commerces
eh bien on ferme et combien ont ouvert
voilà la réalité les gens le peuvent le
voir tous les jours en se promenant dans
notre ville le souci qu'on a sur nevers
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a un souci de
sécurité au sein du ce
entre ville et de la périphérie et un
souci de propreté
voilà les neuf et reçoit pourquoi ils
délaissent le centre ville c'est sur une
question de sécurité de propreté et bien
sûr d'attractivité de stationnement
comme on a pu en parler alors qu'on
vient voir la quatrième fleur qui nous
réconforte pour la propreté
je rappelle qu'elle moins de 300 villes
en france pour la quatrième fleur allez
on vous laisse à l'errance entre les le
verso s était avec eux et vous verrez si
on vous parle pas on enchaîne avec la
série et je me suis un peu la suite
qu'on avance un tout petit peu j'étais à
d'emblée je voulais juste dire un mot
sur la gratuité des transports denis
thuriau et denis curio dit que la
gratuité ça n'existe pas et il ya
toujours quelque 100 bornes qu'il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui paie bien mais ça
veut dire mais c'est d'ailleurs vrai
pour l'école gratuite pour la santé
gratuite pour les routes gratuite donc
dans notre programme
il est clair que on souhaite aller vers
la gratuité transport c'est un c'est un
axe fort de notre programme et donc on a
on a on a fait quelques calculs ça
coûterait 1,4 million
vous avez un million quatre c'est la
baisse des recettes a annoncé d'agglo
sur 43 millions bonus est pas le sens de
reverser je vais vous nous donnez la
parole comme vous comme vous me dites la
barre moment là donc je voudrais juste
dire que pour nous c'est une mesure à la
fois écologique et sociale et à ce titre
elle nous semble importante être mises
en oeuvre
alors bon je voulais revenir sur
l'augmentation des impôts puisque en
fait pour l'instant les noeuds vers soi
ne l'ont peut-être pas encore tout à
fait constater mais que ça arrivera de
fait puisque de nombreux investissements
ont été mis en oeuvre par rapport aux à
la rénovation de certains bâtiments et
que de fait les impôts vont augmenter
pour les neuf et reçoit donc si certains
travaux étaient tout à fait nécessaire
je pense que le meilleur choix aurait
été celui de faire d'investissements sur
les transports notamment qui servent
sans doute augmenter une partie des
impôts mais qui sont aussi financés par
les taxes qui sont versés par les
entreprises et donc c'est là encore une
question de choix
donc il y à des choix que l'on peut
faire qui vont être au service de tous
des noeuds vers soi qui sont en
difficulté financière et qui leur
permettront de se déplacer de manière
gratuite
alors ça peut nous permettre d'avancer
alors on va le faire plus rapidement
parce que mais on a décidé de parler des
transports et c'était le bon moment pour
le faire
on s'était dit qu'on allait parler des
jeunes et de cette questionnement garder
les jeunes à nevers avec de quoi faire
des études ou les faire revenir ça nous
pousse un peu vers l'idée vous parliez
des impôts donc moi je pense impôts et
je pense infrastructures et
investissement est-ce que nevers être
une ville aujourd'hui qui a les
infrastructures qu'elle devrait avoir
rapporté à sa taille
ça peut être un facteur d'attractivité
jus de l'extérieur le stade il n'est pas
bien jeune la salle de sport elle n'est
pas bien je n'ai salle de spectacles
font pas hyper moderne
denis thuriau est-ce que
c'était avant ah je sais pas je vous
trouve une ville en ruine je pense en
auversois mais je m'attendais pas ce que
j'ai souvenir que vous vous êtes et
charles égalisant sur une piscine
pendant la moitié du débat donc au coeur
du débat non c'est pas celle que vous
vouliez à quel prix oui mais c'est pas
celle que d'autres voulaient faire si je
me rappelle bien qu'aucune version
voilà j'ai fait des millions de moins
deux fosses communes de façon simple est
ce que les uns ne verrait pas en retard
par rapport à certaines villes de la
taille sur les infractions mais elle est
depuis très longtemps et se retient de
le rattraper dans des six ans est
rattrapé y avait un nom d'investissement
la ville à peu près avec 280 euros par
habitant en investissement alors que des
villes de même taille c'est plus de 330
euros
donc effectivement j'ai un peu endettée
la ville je l'assumé aujourd'hui on est
un taux d'endettement qui est très
raisonnable par rapport à d'autres
villes
j'entends dire que l'agglomération a
globalement catastrophique 111 euros
cents ou 0 châteauroux ses 900 euros
châteauroux a mis le transport gratuit
je rappelle que lé budget transport
c'est les agglomérations c'est pas des
villes et moi je le dis je n'entends pas
augmenter les impôts dans ce combat qui
vient poindre à cette pensée est que si
vous aviez eu envie vous aviez promis dé
baisser pendant trois ans trois points
de fiscalité en bleu arrivé un peu plus
de la moitié parce qu'à l'époque je
n'avais pas la sauce françois hollande
qui nous répond gelés pendant les trois
premières années du mandat et donc je
n'avais pas mettre la ville en
difficulté jeu léger baisser les impôts
la taxe d'habitation aujourd'hui on est
en deçà vue du dessus de la médiane des
villes médiane réaction que tout le
monde avait des ismes en infrastructures
j'essaie de les empêcher de nous arrêter
sur les tendres on a budget transport
vous dit cette vidéo nevers y manque des
choses c'est évident quand on se promène
dans les rues qui ont été rénovés alors
quand on a le nez sur le macadam
c'est magnifique et c'est quand on lève
les yeux qu'on regarde l'aspect dégrader
les appartements on s'aperçoit que là il
ya un véritable effort à faire il faut
terrasser morel a frôlé faire monsieur
le maire sortant il faut le faire en
collaboration avec les autres
collectivités je pense en particulier au
conseil départemental dont je suis
membre et qui travaillent
activement sur la rénovation des
appartements
quand on veut travailler dans son coin
on s'isole savez c'est pas en chine à
las vegas à tel aviv cored willows au
péage entendu pas de l'eau ph est porté
par l'agglomération et le département en
vue de la vente est rien on va vous
exposer le jeu on a parlé de logements
et les autres alors que nous désirons
également c'est que tout ça coûte de
l'argent que ça a été financée en grande
partie par l'emprunt et comme pierre
bérégovoy le disais les emprunts
d'aujourd'hui sont les impôts de demain
est ce que vous vous engagez
actuellement comme dépenses et bien ce
sont nos enfants et nos petits enfants
qui les perd on est partagé et nous nous
sommes dit citoyenne on le dit sans
arrêt mais pourquoi avoir fait cette
piscine là à quoi baltes il fallait
refaire à campus je vous dirais d'heure
commencer par lucie de salaire en plus
on à 2940 étudiants du campus
vous n'êtes pas au courant non illimité
et au cabba la troisième mais ça va
coûter
non il fait les réunit avec salaire
maintenant l'université et accor puces
bd cup et ils ont le secret place d'une
caserne se sont développées c'est une
richesse des étudiants damien beaudry
les étudiants c'est une richesse était
noté mme debons veut parler maintenant
même si on aime on peut partir pour les
scouts appris et je vais bien cours
souligne 30 secondes 2014 on entre on
attend toujours l'entreprise de chinois
qui devait s'installer à nevers mais
pour pour les jeunes ne versez pas une
prison on a le droit de partir et on a
le droit aussi de revenir ce qu'il faut
vraiment s'est accentué comme ça
commence à être fait sur le campus
numérique ou là ces trains portes très
important de proposer cette offre de
formation aux jeunes au niveau des
études supérieures comme on a déjà au
niveau professionnel où il faut
accentuer on a un vivier de jeunes il
n'y a pas de risque que ce soit une
impasse finalement qui reste deux ans
trois ans mais qu'après il puisse pour
rester que nous parce que ça ne fasse
que reporter pas du tout parce que vous
savez très bien c'était le souci quand
les jeunes partaient sur dijon sur
clermont ou sur paris
quand on fait des études sur cinq ou dix
eh ben on s'installe dans une ville on a
un logement ou créer des faux parfois
une famille on a des amis donc c'est là
que c'est compliqué de revenir à partir
du moment où les jeunes pourront rester
sur notre collectivité pourront y vivre
pleinement et resteront ils
s'installeront parce que on a quand même
des richesses à nevers et dans la nièvre
et un confort de vie qu'on n'a pas
justement dans ces grandes métropoles sa
connaissance
bon une première année de médecine c'est
bien je ne vais pas dire le contraire
mais je m'inquiète un peu indécent
quoique a obtenu un prix pour les gens
qui sont pourtant commencé à baisser le
niveau mais aussi voir aller plus loin a
seulement par denis curieux mais aussi
par le conseil départemental c'est bien
de le rappeler sans sommation mais si
vous voulez la région que je crains
c'est que ça ne fidélisent pas les
étudiantes à dire que moi je suis
enseignante chercheur à l'université de
bourgogne sur l antenne de nevers et
nous avons obtenu de haute lutte
finalement un cursus continuer de la
première année de licence en sciences de
l'éducation jusqu'en master 2 à mon avis
c'est préférable c'est préférable à une
première année de médecine dont on ne
sait pas voilà ce qu'est ce qu'elle va
devenir
et puis pour le campus connectés comme
pour la première mais ni un ennemi de
sin il se trouve que c'est de la
visioconférence et vous doutez bien que
ça n'est pas d'enseigner en tant
qu'enseignante qui veut dire qu'il est
possible de mener des études dans de
bonnes conditions sans accompagnement
des amphis aujourd'hui et le taux de
réussite sur les campus numériques est
supérieur au cursus de siècle à
l'affront de france et que les
enseignants ne sont pas nécessaires
moi je voudrais revenir sur un fait
c'est que plutôt que d'aller chercher
sans cesse ailleurs les solutions en
fait les solutions sont sur notre ville
sur notre territoire
il y a des jeunes qui demandent des
choses à nevers pour lesquels rien n'a
été fait par exemple vous avez plusieurs
associations qui ont demandé des choses
notamment un skatepark inverse qui n'a
pas été réalisé il y à des filières qui
sont en souffrance nous n'avons pas de
garagiste à nevers par exemple et puis
surtout nous ce que nous voulons faire
c'est nous appuyer sur le développement
d'une filière d'alimentation ne verse
oise donc en s'appuyant sur les circuits
courts et de développer l'alimentation
au niveau local et pour cela il faut
développer des filières qui vont
permettre d'alimenter c'est le cas de le
dire
les emplois dans ce dans ces secteurs là
dans les secteurs dans lesquels il
manque des ressources dans lesquelles
nous ment compte personnel votre
position sur l'université connectés
éventuellement c'est quoi je partage
l'avis de madame charlie concernant les
emplois des enseignants qui doivent être
des personnes physiques
on veut absolument tout dématérialisé je
pense que c'est ce qui fait défaut dans
notre société le joueur qui de réalité
c'est que nos verts n'aura pas cinq
années de médecine par exemple donc s'il
y aura sa phrase en bon droit se
croisent en interne
oui alors il ya des choses qui sont
mises en place notamment par le conseil
départemental qui vont faire que les
emplois vont être fléché pour que les
médecins qui seront formés reviennent et
s'installe dans notre ville ou dans le
département qu'ils soient fidéliser
ainsi parce par ce mécanisme de contrat
en fait puisqu'on leur offre leur
formation et qu' ils viennent ensuite se
réinstaller il nous reste pas beaucoup
de temps avant les conclusions 8 9
minutes
un petit mot quand même sur la dimension
environnementale on sait que les très
présente
nathalie charles kao formule était
d'envoyer l'armée man hulk et vous
abordiez ça je lui rappeler qu'à 600
étudiants de plus depuis 2014 adverse et
que les jeunes 18-24 ans constitue
presque 10% de la population les
meilleurs français 6 6% et ne s'est pas
une ville sans jaune et jeu et il m'en
faut trouver les bonnes et je suis
obsessionnel et des jeunes sont très peu
mais pas la dimension environnementale
et climatique au-delà tout le monde veut
que les maires fasse quelque chose moi
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
de façon assez bref finalement assez
ramassé c'est pour un maire ou pour des
candidats à la mairie
c'est quoi l'action d'un maire ou d'un
futur ou d'une future mère sur le
réchauffement climatique et
l'environnement damien beaudry vous
feriez quoi vous pour que pour
contribuer comme le colibri
je pensais que vous aimeriez mais vous
allez l'avoir je mettrai en place et ce
que met le rassemblement national aurait
été un peu je mets en place ce que met
en place donc le rassemblement national
dans les différentes communes qu'on a eu
en 2014 qui sont par ailleurs je
voudrais le souligner est très bien
dirigés et où tous les maires vont être
réélu certainement par le caribou
environnement mais dès le premier tour
c'est pour le souligner que le
rassemblement national l'essayer c'est
l'adopter et sept plateaux mais ça
pourrait voter pour le pour le localisme
c'est sûr que comme disait ma collègue
d'en face c'est bien les circuits courts
à mettre en place pour pour nous pour
nos écoles c'est très important c'est
pour ça que nous par exemple on propose
des choses pour pour d'un point de vue
écologique et qui peut être agréable de
tous c'est par exemple pour un arbre
abattu qui un arbre d'ornement de
planter un arbre fruitier qui soit
planté sur la ville je vous fait avancer
que je veux tout le monde n'aura pas le
temps de s'exprimer sur ce sujet ce
serait bien qu'on en dise un petit mot
alors très bien
il faut savoir qu'il ya 60 à 70% des
leviers d'action pour l'écologie qui se
situe au niveau local donc c'est
important je voudrais dire que la
mandature qui vient de s'achever n'a pas
rempli le contrat
dans le plan climat il était prévu une
diminution de 20 % des gaz à effet de
serre on s'en est tenu à 3,2 pour cent
donc on est loin d'avoir respecté ce qui
avait été envisagé
alors nous on ne fait pas de l'écologie
un objet de communication on a fait de
l'écologie tout simplement la clé de
voûte de notre programme et quelques
quelques mesures tout simplement la
gratuité des transports qu'on est là je
veux parlerai aussi du bio dans les
continents le bio dans les cantines à
nevers c'est 5% à dijon ils ont
multiplié par trois le bio dans les
cantines sans surcoût donc voilà c'est
un projet que nous avons et puis le
baromètre des villes cyclables vient de
rendre son verdict ils se trouvent
donc que nevers est plutôt défavorable
au vélo il est dangereux de faire du
vélo à nevers et on veut donc mettre en
place des pistes cyclables qui soit
sécurisé et homogène atteindre quelques
mots sur ce que vous feriez le
développement durable c'est non
seulement une nécessité mais c'est
surtout une opportunité pour les villes
moyennes le développement des circuits
courts pour réduire les coûts de
transport permettant de changer de
d'échanger des produits à haute valeur
ajoutée
le développement des énergies
renouvelables est également favorable à
la création d'emplois la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments c'est un zizou
en clé dans quoi locaux le développement
des technologies de l'information de
l'écologie ci constitue lui aussi à
viviez créateurs d'emplois et puis à
nouveau à 10 durable à travers notamment
la construction de logements consommant
peu de ressources énergétiques et
abordable par rapport aux métropoles
ainsi que de légende c'est que deux
logements participatifs nature you sur
toutes ces propositions il y en avait
fait autant l'élu 2014 territoire fcv
c'était ségolène royal que la mise en
place on est allé chercher des millions
d'euros qui nous aident notamment rénové
mais noda culture j'ai buté d'empreintes
de même chez nous mais s'est fait
inviter à faire mon inculture posons
zéro déchet zéro gaspillage le
compostage les poules des mesures
parfois très simples pour éviter
justement un certain nombre de
désagréments
gros enjeu qui a envie comme des
ressources naturelles j'ai envie d'être
provocateur la gratuité du stationnement
c'est pas très environnementale
d'utiliser sa voiture
et bien non mais tout ce sont six
aujourd'hui j'arrête les voitures en
centre-ville je tue le centre ville
contre moi ce qui était fini des six ans
maman dit jamais deux autres commerces
en centre-ville qf que tu m'aimais ce
qui ferme c'est une première il ya un
ralentissement de la baisse d'habitants
qui était jusqu'à 1000 habitants par an
aujourd'hui la 240 sont les flots midi 7
6 3 denis thuriau tenait à rappeler cela
donc vous voyez bien que l'élevage sa
gratuité du bus vous savez ceux qui
prennent le bus gratuit c'est ce qu'ils
font du vélo de la marche pas les
voitures
par contre aménager la ville autrement
en périphérie avec des parkings relais
c'est ce qu'on propose là on arrive à
proposer d'autres solutions gens pour
qu'ils viennent à nos verres et gros
enjeu c'est la préservation des
ressources naturelles
l'hydro électricité photovoltaïque on va
fortement développer mon jeu je le
catalogue afin de trouver voilà
catalogue a été largement développée moi
ce que je regrette c'est que le conseil
départemental travaille sur une étude
très sérieuse sur la transition
écologique et sur le climat jamais la
ville de nevers n'a accepté de se
joindre à nous pour travailler c'est
faux c'est qu'on n'ait pas de race noire
et je suis pas charge
on est dans un débat ça je suis tout à
fait d'accord en mai 2019
il ya une étude sur le climat qui a été
fait par l'ensemble des villes moyennes
ou n'y avait pas participé à cette fois
votre chalet mais non mais c'est que
vous étiez comme ça des idées assez
nettement supérieurs on est tous les
membres du département et sur le concert
mais c'est fou mais vous parlez se
travailler de concert avec vos
administrés l'arrachement à lever les
collectivités
on ya une nette distinction là dessus je
voudrais revenir sur un sujet qui n'a
pas été trop aborder c'est sur la
précarité énergétique et notamment de là
il y a un partenariat à mettre en oeuvre
justement avec le département et la
région pour permettre aux personnes les
plus précaires de lutter contre les
factures qui sont beaucoup trop élevés
et ça c'est une un facteur de réduction
de nos émissions est un facteur de
réduction aussi de la facture pour les
personnes qui ont des difficultés à
payer leurs charges au niveau de douleur
chauffage
je voudrais revenir également sur la
gestion des déchets puisque on sait que
c'est le deuxième poste budgétaire au
niveau dans environnementale des
collectivités et là encore on peut
accentuer largement les efforts quant à
la mise en place d'une plateforme pour
collecter des fermentescibles
ce qui n'a pas été le cas et ensuite
pour recycler l'ensemble de nos déchets
puisque on voit qu'aujourd'hui nous
devons absolument nous orienter vers une
moindre consommation des choses et vers
leur recyclage donc en mettant en place
des filières de avec les ressourceries
notamment les bricothèque qui vont nous
permettre de nous orienter vers
l'économie sociale et il nous reste peu
de temps avant d'arriver aux conclusions
de donner la parole aussi à lutte
ouvrière à dominique dupuis
nous avons enregistré précédemment juste
un petit mot parce qu'on se souvient
qu'aux municipales précédentes et des
alliances entre deux tours à nos vers
moi j'ai envie de demander et je ne
demande pas forcément un déni pur you
est ce que certains d'entre vous sont
prêts à s'entendre dans ces élections ou
pas ce que j'aurai une réponse dans
l'intérêt d'une version aidez-nous
version nous sommes prêts à nous
entendre sur un contrat d'objectifs avec
qui je suis prêt à m'entendre avec les
écologistes éventuellement avec vous
même à condition que nous soyons
d'accord sur la finalité la sortie
l'onglet est ce que c'est un peu une
question piège je conçois mais c'est
peut-être le moment de se poser parce
que ça a été tellement déterminant à
nevers ya six ans karine road again si
vous êtes vous pourriez rejoindre
quelqu'un ou pourriez vous pas bien sûr
toutes les personnes que j'ai embrassé
l'arrivée du studio bien sûr bon écoutez
moi j'ai des voisins en face de moi il
ya sans doute de personnes que je ne
pourrais pas rejoindre mais je ne parle
pas des voisins à côté de moi bon
d'accord je vais rebondir comme comme on
cible il est certain que moi non plus
avec notre liste nous allierons avec
personne au second tour parce que les re
tout les candidats qui sont toutes les
listes porté autour de cette table sont
tous comptables du bilan de ces 25
dernières années ils ont des écologistes
pardon sauf les et sur vasilis vous avez
pas monsieur diot qui a participé au
bilan de ces dernières est un art les
écologistes alors vous portez une liste
où il ya le parti communiste est obligé
de nous arriver parce que c'est lent
même bourré pas conclure et on va
essayer de se tenir à ça avant justement
vos conclusions on écoute dominique
dupuis c'est la tête de liste lutte
ouvrière pour cette élection municipale
à nevers il nous parle de sa candidature
c est faire permettre aux travailleurs
d'exprimer leur colère on est à la suite
du mouvement des gels et jaune de la
réforme contre les retraites
1 parce qu'on estime y en a ras-le-bol
dans cette société de prendre des coups
sans arrêt sans pouvoir les réponses et
nous notre liste c'est justement dans
cette continuité là on veut pas se
résigner
on veut pas sans arrêt prendre des coups
et on veut permettre au travail et ont
justement d'exprimer leur colère à
nevers moi je fais pas de promesses
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse résoudre
les problème fondamental des
travailleurs à l'échelle d'une
municipalité les c'est à dire les
problèmes de fans mois les problèmes de
logement les problèmes d'appel et ça
nous ont dit aux travailleurs que si on
veut les résoudre il faudra les résoudre
dans un mouvement d'ensemble
le reste ça pourra pas se faire au
niveau de la municipalité
alors après cette interview il est temps
de conclure une minute pour chacun
matérialisait par ce sablier virtuel qui
va défiler derrière moi et puis à côté
de vous nous avons tiré au sort votre
ordre de passage avant le débat nous
commençons par emilie chat potté nevers
en commun c'est voter pour le
rassemblement de là
oui nous assumons pleinement nos
étiquettes et revendiquons la diversité
de celle ci nous avons pris nos
responsabilités politiques en nous
unissant pour défendre la justice
sociale contre les politiques libérales
qui aggrave les inégalités
l'élan populaire est le renouvellement
que nous incarnons sont notre fierté et
un bel espoir pour nevers les forces
vives de notre ville ne demande qu'à
être enfin reconnue et entendu notre
ville doit retrouver ses espaces communs
sont bon vivre qui a été perdu et c'est
également sa générosité
notre ville de demain doit être celle où
nous pouvons vivre sainement sans
épuiser les ressources dont elle dispose
c'est à dire se loger se nourrir est
également vivre nos activités sans
qu'elles défilent sans qu'elle soit
déterminante pour le pour le sol
la taille comme la situation
géographique de nevers nous offre tout
c'est possible notre salut ne viendra
pas d'ailleurs que de chez nous et il
est en nous il est chez nous je suis je
suis obligé de vous couper ça va défiler
on avait vu une minute damien voudriez
vous de conclure oui donc c'est un
message d'espoir que je veux envoyer aux
9 et reçoit ce soir leur dire que
l'univers n'est pas enfermé entre la
gauche et le maquereau nisme qu'un autre
choix est possible et que si comme moi
ils veulent avoir une ville sûre où les
petits caïds ne font pas la loi mais où
on peut s'installer pour fonder sa
famille notre propre famille
s'ils veulent une ville fière de son
rôle de capitale rural de locomotive du
département c'est comme moi ils ont nos
verres à coeur je les invite le 15 mars
prochain à voter pour la liste du
rassemblement national
merci damien beaudry pour faire de
l'écologie il faut élire des écologistes
est l'échelon local et l'échelon le plus
approprié pour mettre en place une
politique écologiste
il ya deux questions majeures qui se
pose aujourd'hui est la question du
climat et la question des inégalités
sociales
il se trouve que nevers écologique et
solidaire comme son nom l'indiqué va
s'emparer de ces des questions y
répondre par ailleurs je suis une femme
entourée d'une équipe soudée et
cohérente avec laquelle nous travaillons
depuis plus d'un an et demi nous avons
un programme solide sérieux et nous
sommes prêts à prendre les rênes de la
mairie
rien n'arrête une idée dont le temps est
venu et le temps de l'écologie et de la
solidarité est venu si vous votez pour
nevers écologique et solidaire vous
votez pour la gratuité des transports
par exemple vous voté aussi pour la
tarification progressive de l'eau dont
je n'avais pas parlé tout à l'heure vous
votez pour le fait que plus on trie ses
déchets - an payent et vous votez pour
un moratoire contre l'extension des
zones commerciales périphériques par
exemple merci beaucoup la télé charbit
karine leroy bagasse et à votre compte
en conclusion je veux m'adresser aux 9
heures soit une version à ce qui nous
regarde où leur dire que le 15 mars
prochain
leur but faire la différence notre
programme c'est le programme de tous les
noeuds vers soir c'est eux qui l'ont
conçu nous voulons faire de nevers une
ville dynamique qui attire des
entreprises et qui créent des emplois
nous voulons faire de nevers une ville
sur une ville propre qui protège sur
l'environnement nous voulons faire de
nos vers une ville remarquable qui fait
rayonner son patrimoine avec une équipe
motivée généreuse et courageuse une
équipe qui vous ressemblent pour un
projet qui vous rassemble osons faire
des noeuds vers une ville belle et forte
osons le vert veux tu es un numéro sur
la liste que je préside rassemble à la
fois des femmes et des hommes de culture
de gauche
elle est d'ailleurs soutenue par la
section socialiste pierre bérégovoy de
nevers et également des femmes et des
hommes centriste libéral
socioprofessionnelles s'ils ont décidé
de s'allier pour l'avenir de nevers
notre ambition c'est d'abord de
réconcilier les noeuds vers soi c'est
elena versoix il est intolérable que
nous ayons cette espèce de diers de
tranchées depuis six ans entre les
noeuds vers soir et l'une vers soi
il faut également se tourner vers
l'ensemble de ces quartiers défavorisés
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure que 22% des
neuf et reçoit vivent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
et bien notre principal challenge c'est
de redonner dignité à l'ensemble de ces
populations et de leur apporter avec
toutes les difficultés que cela présente
l'emploi merci philippe morel denis
thuriau le tirage au sort vous a donné
la dernière position
il ya six ans vous avez décidé de
choisir une autre voie en confiant la
municipalité à nevers à venir le 15 mars
vous aurez le choix entre ce mouvement
qui perdure qui a réalisé 95% de ses
engagements et nous en sommes fiers
parce que nous l'avons fait pour vous
vous aurez le choix entre une liste
communiste écologique
d'extrême gauche vous aurez le choix
entre une liste surnaturel improbable
ayant sorti du formol les anciens
socialistes qui ont plombé la ville de
nevers
vous aurez chantre une longue d'extrême
droite et vous aurez le choix entre une
lisse copier-coller qu'il ya de cela
j'ai d'ailleurs notre programme est bien
notre mouvement est le seul à rassembler
l'ensemble des neuf et reçoit et le sol
a rassemblé l'ensemble des tendances
républicaine qu'elle soit de gauche du
centre ou de droite ou d'aucune
appartenance politique c'est ce choix
que je vous propose de renouveler nous
avons l'envié nous avons travaillé notre
projet avec vous et donc nous sommes
tous prêts à continuer cet nouvel élan
nous avons donné à nos verts quand je
dis continuez c'est là que nous et nous
serons les seuls à pouvoir le faire dès
le lendemain
donc j'ai envie de vous dire une seule
liste à retenir ses 9 heures à venir
et pour bien voter faut voter 4
figurez-vous 4 c'est l'équilibré c'est
pile au milieu des panneaux électoraux
merci denis thuriau cette fois c'est
terminé pour notre débat merci à tous
les six d'être venu jouer le jeu du
débat et de l' échange de points de vue
et d'arguments pas toujours facile
restez bien sûr avec nous autour de la
table mercredi prochain on vous donne
rendez vous à 21h pour deux autres
débats dijon essence et puis n'oubliez
pas le 15 mars premier tour les soirées
électorales ce sera chez nous sur france
3 vous le saurez tout de 20h à 23h
on vous attend on est prêt bonne soirée
merci au revoir
[Musique]